hi I'm Erik Bosse in the recent
spider-man far from home trailer really
tore us for a loop simply by showing us
a spider-man that isn't just a suit
filled with dust
spider-man's dead we saw it happen twice
no one in this trailer talking about it
now I'm sure the MCU is in in denial and
ventures endgame will present us with a
very clear explanation of how spider-man
Nick Fury and Maria hill and perhaps
some other characters could be alive
once more and to be clear the answer
isn't far from home taking place before
infinity war it's been confirmed
particular least after endgame let's not
go down that road again
this far from home footage is shown us
the aftermath of the events of endgame
and if you watch it closely the trailer
actually gave us a number of clues that
hint at which Marvel heroes could be
alive after endgame and which ones might
not be let's dig into this and as warned
against it and I predicted it'll rain
and I ruin your life
ok let's refresh ourselves with the
current death toll as we know it to be
coming out of the recent Marvel films
during the events of infinity war we saw
Loki Heimdall Gamora envision straight
up croak sure Loki will probably come
back somehow for the Disney Plus series
ensure maybe vision has been downloaded
on some misplaced hard drive but for now
dead and in the decimation event of
Thanos to snap we saw the following
characters fade into dust Peter Parker
Black Panther Scarlet Witch Bucky Doctor
Strange Falcon star-lord Drax Groot
mantis Nick Fury Maria Hill and at the
end of ant-man the wasp we saw Hank Pym
hope Van Dyne and Janet Van Dyne join
them after Infinity Ward came out the
Russo brothers also confirm that among
the dusted are Betty Ross Bruce banners
ex and Lady SIF from the Thor movies
sorry ladies now as for those left alive
we got Tony Stark cap Thor Bruce Banner
Black Widow Rhodey nebula rocket Ocoee
and Baku judging from the end of ant-man
the wasp and the Avengers end game
trailer Scott Lang has survived despite
the avengers considering him missing
according to the trailer Hawkeye also
survived even if a lot of his hair
didn't I think we can assume that Wong
is safe along with Shuri whom we last
saw lying on the ground after a scuffle
with Corvus glaive in the end game
trailer she was also listed as missing
Captain Marvel of course is probably
alive though it would be pretty
hilarious if Nick Fury's outgoing pager
message ends up going to a pile of Carol
Danvers dust Jon Favreau confirmed that
happy hogan would be alive an in-game
and the Russo said Aunt May's survived
the snap as well
meanwhile they said Ned's fate was too
much of a spoiler to reveal at that
point along with Corrigan meek and Jane
Foster
Thor's ex and just recently some leaked
merchandise hinted that Valkyrie could
be alive an endgame as well and some set
images of Gwyneth Paltrow and a costume
we haven't seen yet suggests that Pepper
Potts must have survived - but how does
this recent spider-man far from home
trailer change these lists well
obviously spider-man Nick Fury and Maria
Hill moved from the dusted category to
the alive one Ned also moves from being
unknown to being alive so much for that
spoiler and if you look closely at that
big charity check that happy carries you
can see Pepper Potts signature so she is
confirmed to be alive now as well
meanwhile the trailer features a
conspicuous absence of any other avenger
notably Tony Stark who was previously a
mentor to Peter Parker in the past
movies Iron Man and Thor do get
mentioned this trailer but they aren't
around so what happened an endgame who's
gonna live who gonna die it's like we've
gotten this brief limited glimpse of the
future with this far from home trailer
and we're trying to use clues from that
future dream to extrapolate backwards
and Warner friends that they're about to
die all without getting distracted by
Jake Gyllenhaal who I'm sure shows up in
many of your dreams so let's make some
predictions okay Peter Parker Nick Fury
Maria Hill along with star-lord Groot
Drax mantis and Black Panther Doctor
Strange I think we'll survive avengers
endgame I've gone into several possible
ways that these characters could
resurrect from dust going back in time
to reset the timeline splitting into a
parallel reality in the multiverse where
these characters are still alive or the
infinity war survivors making some kind
of cosmic sacrifice to trade lives these
theories can't all be the accurate one
but one of them might be so go watch
these videos thanks what this far from
home trailer does tell us is that Marvel
phase four intends on moving forward
with the sequels to phase three movies
regardless of whatever happened in
infinity war an endgame and a spider-man
survives I think we can assume survival
for the others like we know a sequel for
Doctor Strange is coming along with the
guardians of the galaxy vol 3 and with
Black Panthers recent awards recognition
you better believe Kevin Feige you will
want to produce another one of those I
think we could trust that Nick Fury
ain't going anywhere
good point fury however that snap gets
reversed to reset it's not gonna reset
Nick Fury's depth perception problems
and you know I'm gonna go out on a limb
and make another less confident
prediction Iron Man and Thor will
survive of interest in Game two
please don't come back to haunt me the
farm for a moment trailer mentioned both
of these characters by name he's like
Iron Man and Thor rolled into one he's
no Spider Man look around at these kids
no one looks at least bit sad or
mournful at these mentions of Iron Man
or Thor so may be Iron Man Thor just
missing which I guess is less sad or
maybe these kids are sociopaths
or maybe due to like time travel the
heroes could have died in the distant
past which would be enough time to
grieve whatever I just think they're
alive Robert Downey jr. and Chris
Hemsworth with the success of Thor
Ragnarok are hugely popular stars for
the Marvel brand that can still make a
lot of money for a lot of people and if
we're going down this road of course I
mean these two survive I think there's a
good chance that most of the others will
too
like why keep Ironman alive and then
kill Rhodey off they already got so
close to doing that Civil War he's just
getting back on his legs don't feel mean
and Black Widow has her own solo film
coming out and we gotta see Hulk and
Thor together again really the only
character I think will not survive in
game is cap I know with Infinity Ward
the Russos shocked us with the breadth
of casualties so many deaths within game
I think they're gonna shock us with the
depth of one very emotional loss Steve
Rogers has always been the selfless hero
the guy to jump on the grenade if cap is
given a chance to sacrifice some stuff
to bring back even one of the Fallen
Heroes this guy's gonna take it no there
could be a way cap doesn't die but still
gets permanently separated from everyone
like I'd brought up this idea before
that he could use time travel to stay in
the 1940s and live the life that he
always wanted to live look that would be
nice
maybe Bucky could join him but I just
got a gut feeling that this will be the
last time we see Robert Downey jr. Tony
Stark and Chris Evans Captain America
appear in a movie together
my guts been wrong before I just don't
feel good about this for the question
I'm leaving me with I'm gonna let you
play God or play Thanos he's basically
God now between Stark Thor and cap if
you could kill off one of them to spare
the lives of the other two who would you
kill comment down below follow us
subscribe to this channel and subscribe
to our new podcast
where ever you listen to podcasts
especially if you use the Emily app
because subbing through the Himalaya app
will help them help us release new shows
and
if you live in the LA area come see my
live comedy show darkest timeline comedy
starring me
comedians some new rock stars guests
Friday February 1st of the Acme Theatre
in North Hollywood thanks for watching
and I realize now that I just asked you
to play fmk with the Avengers who are we
the girls was right a man homecoming s
Thor Mary Iron Man and kill him Jill
Hawk
nice job spoiling Avengers end game
Betty
[Music]